doesn't be for me mr. speaker the Prime
Minister of Israel hey Lou i feel i am
representing all the citizens of Israel
even those who do not agree with my own
a representative are the entire Jewish
people I speak for all Jews including
the ones who don't want me to that's now
coming to six today is just another
example of fear-mongering and knowing
the real issues people should be talking
about what's actually happening in
Israel and Palestine instead I took the
transcriptions of all the previous
speeches that Netanyahu had already and
I removed all the sentences that are
aimed to create fear and once I remove
these it was left with no content today
we dissolve reprehensible significations
the configure our convergence is just a
gesture of inviting people to imagine
what they would like to do and what they
see is wrong just take on an active
position articulate what is wrong and
speak up today I wish to unveil a new
Israeli technology a bullshit powered
spacecraft that will take the first
settlers to Mars now in Israel we have a
lot of bullshit standing ovations to get
in a year's worth of squat workout
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is coming back